In Britain, the reaction to the Panama Papers
leak has been a bit weird.
Politicians have been releasing summaries
of their tax returns,
all falling over each other to try and prove
that they haven't got any offshore accounts
or arguing strongly that they shouldn't have
to prove
that they don't have any offshore accounts.
One of them said that requiring politicians
to have public tax returns
was "reminiscent of the Stasi or the KGB".
Welcome to Norway. Behind me is the Oslo tax
office.
And if you want to know what a politician
earns here, you can just ask them.
It's not just politicians, though.
It's everyone. Tax returns in Norway, Sweden
and Finland have been public for years:
the countries differ on how much detail they
provide,
and whether you need to have a good reason
for asking --
but fundamentally the amount you earn is public
knowledge here.
Now, at this point, we could do the news report
thing,
and cut to interviews with Norwegian people
on the street,
asking how they feel about this.
Or: we could science it,
and look at a paper by economist Ricardo Perez-Truglia
of Microsoft Research.
That paper combines two things: first, the
Norwegian Monitor Survey,
which, every two years, surveys a representative
sample of Norwegians
and includes questions about happiness and
life satisfaction.
And second, when finding out someone else's
tax details went from
"you have to go here and look through a book,
"and you've only got three weeks in the year
to do it"
to "a newspaper has published everything online
and there's a search box".
The paper concludes that wage transparency,
that knowing whether you're keeping up with
the Joneses,
or the Johansens,
doesn't make the populace happier overall.
Instead, it increases the happiness gap:
knowing for certain you're being paid more
than your neighbours
makes you more likely to be satisfied with
your life.
Knowing for certain that you're not doing
as well? That hurts.
You can still look up people's tax returns
online in Norway, by the way.
But lately, you have to log in as a taxpayer
yourself,
and everyone can see the records of who's
been searching for them.
That's a whole different social game right
there.
But there is another good argument for wage
transparency:
that it makes for a fairer world.
There's no strong data on that yet, not that
I can find,
and it'd be extremely difficult to measure.
But there's some good anecdotal evidence,
particularly from an engineer at Google who
created a spreadsheet
where their colleagues could voluntarily share
their salaries.
The story around it, and how management reacted
to that, is well worth a read.
And there's also evidence that,
although politicians might not like it,
public disclosure of tax returns does reduce
tax evasion.
So does this mean I'm about to share my tax
return,
and report to the world how much I made last
year?
No. Because I'm British,
because we don't talk about money,
you might find out something you don't want
to know...
or you might hurt someone else.
So my reaction to wage transparency is the
same as a lot of people's:
you first.
[Translating these subtitles? Add your name
here!]